heads up folks major Avengers infinity
war spoilers coming your way I'll listen
to you till this is empty the
super-sized Marvel blockbuster dished
out very little mercy in it's
heartbreaking ending that saw big-name
heroes bite the dust literally while
some characters fates were seemingly
sealed others were left up for
interpretation
like Valkyrie in the Asgardians who
didn't appear in the film
now infinity war co-director Joe Russo
has revealed what happened to Tessa
Thompson's hard-drinking Valkyrie and
the rest of the Asgardian refugees that
is unless you choose to take Thompson's
word that she was in fact in the film as
well a baby goat for refresher infinity
war picks up where thor ragnarok left
off with the tense scene aboard the
grandmasters refugee vessel that carried
Thor Loki Hulk Heimdall Valkyrie and the
rest of the rescued citizens of Asgard
Thanos and his Black Order battered Thor
in an attempt to extract the space stone
from the tesseract then stabbed Heimdall
through the chest intercepted Hulk and
offed Loki infinity war then carried on
directly after Loki took his last breath
not bothering to address Valkyrie in the
remaining as guardians during a Q&A at
his old high school in Iowa City Joe
Russo confirmed that Valkyrie survived
thanasis surprise attack a student who
attended Russo's presentation took to
Reddit to relay the information the user
wrote he did confirm that Valkyrie lived
Russo didn't reveal exactly how the
heroine made it out alive but given that
he mentioned a portion of the Asgardians
on the ship had fled using escape pods
it's safe to assume that Valkyrie may
have done the same
though ducking away from a major battle
doesn't quite seem like something
Valkyrie would do perhaps she was tasked
with ensuring the last as Guardians
evacuated safely sadly those wondering
what happened to Korg the adorable
cronin warrior voiced by thor ragnarok
director Taika Waititi won't be as
pleased with Russo's remarks made of
rooks as you can see but don't get that
intimidate you you don't need to be
afraid
unless you're made of scissors just a
little rock papers as a joke for you the
same reddit user indicated that they
asked Russo whether cork survived the
ambush but the filmmaker answered that
he wasn't quote willing to say what his
fate was at least not at this time so he
habit Marvel fans a bunch of our
precious heroes may be gone for good but
Val
curry is definitely still alive silver
linings right thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]